[Music]  [Music]  oh  [Music]  um  first learned about this seven years ago  on a mission in brazil  to capture a wanted fugitive  when we got there it tore through our  unit in seconds  the target has superhuman abilities  [Applause]  [Music]  it had the same marking you do cole  it's a birthmark what do you mean he was  born with it  it's not a birthmark cole means you've  been chosen  throughout history different cultures  all over the world  reference a great tournament  world champions that dragon marking  i think it's an invitation to fight for  something known  as mortal kombat  these are your champions i'm sonya  that's kano i'm luke  jax  the fate of earth is in our hands  no matter how many of my people you put  in the ground  we will not fail kill them  i am subzero  get over here  you [ __ ] beauty  you